excel kostet die weltwirtschaft
milliarden es ist traurig aber wahr
schuld sind die zahlreichen fehler die
sich schnell in komplexe tabellen
einschleichen
jetzt ein klick zum science fiction ein
tortendiagramm oder darf es ein
balkendiagramm seien mit excel lassen
sich nicht nur auszahlen gute
schaubilder basteln es hilft bei der
kalkulation von etats kann funktionen
berechnen und natürlich bei der
erstellung von statistiken helfen und
excel ist das verbreitetste programm
dieser art weltweit ungefähr 750
millionen menschen nutzen es und damit
umzugehen will gelernt sein und da
passieren immer wieder fehler und die
können fatale auswirkungen haben excel
wird natürlich auch von
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern benutzt und
deren berechnungen können die
entscheidung in der politik zum beispiel
stark beeinflussen gerade in der
weltweiten finanzkrise in den letzten
jahren ist es dazu einigen
fehlberechnungen bekommen deren folgen
in den kommenden jahren auch noch
spürbar sein könnten vielleicht ist der
sparzwang für griechenland oder andere
stark verschuldete staaten genau der
falsche weg
aber der reihe nach die ökonom kenneth
rogoff und carmen reinhart wollten in
ihren studien herausgefunden haben dass
das wirtschaftswachstum eines landes
stark abfällt wenn die schulden rate
über 90 prozent steigt diese kennzahl
stellt die wirtschaftsleistung eines
landes mit der verschuldung gegenüber
das wird einfach so berechnet
verschuldung durch bruttoinlandsprodukt
also wenn diese zahl über 90 prozent
steigt soll es in den betreffenden
ländern ein negatives
wirtschaftswachstum geben es schrumpft
also und das wäre fatal und deswegen
galt dieser wert diese 90 immer als
argument für einsparungen darauf war sie
jetzt sozusagen die ganze euro
rettungspolitik wenn griechenland
wirtschaftlich wieder wachsen will muss
es sparen so die annahme rogoff und
reinhart kam zu diesem ergebnis mit
hilfe einer excel-tabelle sie bestimmten
die zellen mit zahlen zur verschuldung
und dem wirtschaftswachstum von
verschiedenen industrie und
schwellenländern
gingen sogar bis zum jahr 1790 zurück
und so kamen sie auf die kennziffer 90
allerdings sind den beiden bei der
eingabe der zahlen einige fehler
passiert
das hat nur niemand bemerkt bis sich der
volkswirtschaft student thomas herden
von der university of massachusetts zwei
jahre der veröffentlichung im rahmen
einer semesterarbeit mit der studie
beschäftigte werden wollte was üblich
ist die ergebnisse der studie
reproduzieren kam mit den öffentlich
zugänglichen daten allerdings nicht auf
das gleiche ergebnis
daher schrieb die ökonomin reinhardt an
und die schickte ihm einfach die ganze
excel-tabelle rüber werden fand sehr
schnell den fehler in einigen formen
fehlten einige wichtige excel zahlen die
daten von australien belgien dänemark
kanada und österreich wurden so einfach
nicht mitberechnet sie waren tatsächlich
einfach vergessen worden
dazu kam noch dass die wirtschaftsdaten
einiger ländern nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg fehlen das fatale an diesen
fehler korrigiert man sie kommt man zu
einem völlig anderen ergebnis aus einem
negativen wachstum wird ein positives
statt minus 0 1 prozent wachstum sind es
40 plus 22 prozent
das stellt natürlich alle entscheidungen
die auf grund dieser studie gefällt
worden sind in frage und das war nur ein
beispiel für den fehlerhaften umgang mit
dem kalkulationsprogramm diese fehler
innerhalb der excel-tabelle gelten als
anfängerfehler experten haben in der
arbeit mit dem programm einige
gefahrenquellen entdeckt und die sitzen
meistens vor den bildschirmen dabei
können setzt leuten fehler unterlaufen
die sich mit der software gut auskennen
oft spielen auch zeit und geld eine
rolle in einem unternehmen wird eine
tabelle oft nur von einer oder nur
wenigen personen erstellt es gibt kaum
kontrollinstanzen die die arbeit
verifizieren
wenn du eine person die tabelle erstellt
ist das vertrauen in die eigene arbeit
oft sehr hoch auch die kollegen
hinterfragen die meistens nicht so
werden tabellen weitergereicht und nicht
überprüft mit den ergebnissen werden
womöglich weitere tabellen erstellt ein
kleiner fehler eine übersehene zeile und
am ende kommt eine völlig falsche
kalkulation heraus deren ursprung dann
nur schwer zurückverfolgbar
94 prozent also ich 94 prozent aller
excel tabellen gibt es fehler dass
tabellen nicht nachgeprüft werden hilft
auch denjenigen die absichtlich falsche
daten generieren weil sie damit etwas
ganz bestimmtes erreichen wollen
jeder der schon mal was mit statistiken
zu tun hat kennt das sprichwort trau
keiner statistik die du nicht selbst
gefälscht hast
so lassen sie studien manipulieren und
die öffentliche wahrnehmung steuern bei
kaffee jetzt gesund oder nicht ist
butter gesund oder nicht ist der mensch
schuld an der erderwärmung oder nicht
wie viel co2 stößt ein pkw aus zu fast
allen themen gibt es statistiken die
einen zeigen dieses ergebnis die anderen
ein anderes gegen den betrug lässt sich
von vornherein nur wenig machen man
sollte sich die ergebnisse einer studie
jedoch immer genau anschauen um
herauszufinden wie diese interpretiert
wurden um fehler durch menschliche
nachlässigkeit zu verhindern werden seit
dem jahr 2000 jährlich tagung der
european spreadsheet riss interviews
club kurz sprick veranstaltet hier
sollen standards im umgang mit excel
gefunden werden
der vorsitzende der kzbv patrick ob ein
kritisiert vor allem dass fehler oft
nicht eingestanden werden und man lieber
an der eigenen scheinbaren und
fehlbarkeit festhalte eine gute
entwicklung sieht ob ein in der
verlegung der tabellen vom eigenen
rechner in die cloud so hat jeder
mitarbeiter zugang zur gleichen version
der tabelle und fehler können so
schneller aufgedeckt werden
habt ihr auch schon mal probleme mit
excel gehabt oder habt ihr euch bei
einer studie gefragt ob die überhaupt
zustimmen kann schreibt und diskutiert
in den kommentaren
schaut euch das nächste video an lasst
ein kostenloses abo da und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt